black
i thought that was heavy
black means beautiful intelligent
empowered
strong black power black people black
panther
beautiful i don't even know if that
needs much context
the first thing that comes to mind when
i hear the word black is black lives
matter
i see the word apologetic
proud resilient i think of innovative
i love the word black i feel a lot of
pride in being black
beautiful misunderstood taken advantage
of
beautiful the
first peoples i love black people i love
everything it is about being black
except
what it means to everybody else and just
based off of everything everything from
political to religion it just seems to
be
an influx of negativity when
african-american men or women are
mentioned
in any capacity frustration
struggle i feel like black people
misunderstood as far as a race because
we are the probably the most forgiving
race based on the things that have
happened to us
throughout our history from a young age
black people are taught to be sorry
and i don't know what we're sorry for
like we really don't have anything to be
sorry for but that's what you're taught
that you should be
police violence racism and a group of
people
who have done an incredible job at
staying alive
i think of someone who never gives up
harriet tubman malcolm x
martin luther king jr strength
resiliency
black love black girl magic yeah all
those good things
black is beautiful and that's the thing
that i was thankfully able to say
very early on thanks to my mom and my
parents and the people that i grew
up with oh it's awesome we're pretty
internally i love the word black
because it just it's me
you